this is a production of cornell
university
today we're at bristol's nursery and
we're going to be talking about
production method particularly
container production for our landscape
jobs so typically there are three
different types of production method in
other words how you grow the tree
one is bald and burlap which is b and b
which is a
wire basket lined with burlap the tree
grows in that
that's very heavy the other one is
container growing
which we'll be talking about mostly here
and there's another one which we'll see
in another video
called bare root planting but today
we're going to concentrate on container
growing
and what that means and how you use it
so one of the big advantages of
container growing is
you're growing a plant in lightweight
media that i can pick up
very easily if i would try to do this
with a soil medium it would be
probably four times heavier so
lightweight
easy to grow you get a very uniform
product here
in a container nursery and
it's easy you can actually grow it plant
it at any time of the year because you
take the root system with
the plant in the plastic pot and that's
a big advantage for the grower
and for the contractor who's putting in
the job for you
so let's walk over here and see the
different container sizes
so typically we specify containers in
different
sizes this is the smallest one we use
what's called a number one
this is number two number three
and number five these are the different
containers are typically grown for small
shrubs understory ground cover type work
when you get into small trees you can
actually get into larger sizes
here's a number 10 and then
a number 15 and a number 20
here and you can see these are all
cornice plants that are grown
in different container sizes and as
these grow
they would be up potted into a larger
size container
so they continue to grow and not become
restricted
so one of the disadvantages of container
growing
is that if you let the tree grow in the
pot for too long
the roots can become circled and
restricted
the other thing about disadvantages of
container growing is because we are on a
lightweight
soilless media sometimes water movement
between the soilless media and the
ground
can become restricted especially when
you're doing this in summer
so there are advantages and
disadvantages but
most of our plant material is grown in
containers especially shrubs
and ground covers that's where we'll see
most of that those plants come from
oh we're just walking around the nursery
and we found these liner pots
these are not typically what we plant
but it could be for a particular job
these are very small three-inch square
pots
with a seedling or a grafted plant
in the very young stages before it gets
potted up to a larger size
in some cases we might want to use small
material in a job
but that's not typically what we do
nina just introduced us to the container
plant
and talked a little bit about advantages
and disadvantages and also introduced
the container size so how do we use the
container size how does that relate to
specifying and design work well uh
really there's a relationship between
the size of the container
and the size of the plant might go
without saying
but uh that relationship is actually
standardized
in a common document called ansi z60.1
the american nursery standard and we'll
share that document with you
what it does is it explains uh as a
at regular intervals what size root mass
for a shrub plant like this uh relates
to what size
plant above ground here's a plant that's
just been up potted actually
into the appropriate container size
so we actually have two varieties of
plants here
and two different size so when we're
specifying
what we would like to have installed in
a project
we're always going to talk about the
size of the plant not the container
but it's important to understand that
there's a relationship there and you're
going to see
see how that plays out here uh when
we're specifying we also
uh always use a range interval
to talk about the size we want because
one plant in one container
class that would have one cost actually
will be at a
inter different range of sizes at any
given time
so here we have three units
that range from 18 to 24 inches and a
number five
short container so for this case we
would specify you know
plant acts uh 18 to 24 inches
and this is what would show up on site
well so
how does that relate to spacing in the
design
knowing that you have this 18 to 24 inch
high plant
so i'm going to show you an example of
like how these nine plants would lay out
and what kind of spacing they would take
up
for this number five container uh with
these
18-inch plants it'd be typical to space
them about
two times the size of the plant so here
we have
roughly three foot spacing on center
staggered we like to stagger
and not lay out the plants in a straight
line like that
and we'll get more into that at another
time
so here we have the three foot spacing
and then up here
uh in this number two class container
with these plants
between 12 to maybe 15 inches we're
going to space them about
24 to 30 inches apart so here we have
that
give me one second to space them out
all right so what i'm going for here is
a spacing that will allow these plants
uh
in a relatively short amount of time
actually to grow
together and colonize what we call a
closed canopy
and it's important then that we make
sure when we're specifying the plant
size
that we're thinking about plant spacing
and that relationship over time of how
they're going to grow to colonize and
occupy a space
uh the result of them coming together
and going into one monolithic mass
is that with a closed canopy they'll
actually be more self-sustaining
they'll shade the root system which
helps with water retention
and they'll out compete by shading the
area of growth
uh in the open landscape they'll
actually reduce weed recruitment so
they'll prevent weedy species from
invading if we space them too far apart
and they're not able to fill in that
space in again a relatively short period
of time say
one or two years of establishment with
this open space available we're going to
see other plants coming in
in most typical installations that's
really not what we're looking for
is that random effect
so that's more like a typical spacing
these nine plants
we're looking at something like uh
let's take a quick measure
about eight feet by about six feet
area so that's that's about how they
would lay out
so now we've spoken a little bit about
uh you know
the container plant and production
techniques and methods
of potting and then we talked a little
bit about
design standards uh spacing
specifying size and layout and
now finally we're going to talk about
the kind of the last stage
of the journey of the plant from the
production facility
uh maybe through a distributor's yard
but ultimately to
a construction site where it's going to
be installed so
now your plant has been loaded on a
truck at the production facility
or contractor's yard and is coming to
site
at that point you're going to want to be
there to inspect it
do you want to talk a little bit about
that yeah so sure when we
wrote the specification for this plant
we required it to be
of this certain size range and in this
certain pot size
and on the truck it's better to inspect
this on the truck
because no one wants to reload if
anything is rejected to reload it on the
truck and take it away
so on the truck we'd actually inspect
the plant for the size
and pot size that we required also the
health
and contain condition of the plant so
it's not
diseased or dead parts or anything that
would be rejected
so once we said that it's yes it's our
size it's our pot
it looks good then we want to uh store
the plant
in an area on the job site so that it's
going to be protected
before planting occurs this is a very
difficult often a very difficult time
for the plant because
it had to be in a shady spot mulched and
watered
critically it's important to water them
realizing that in the nursery these pots
were watered every day because of the
lightweight medium
that's right so at the end of that stage
where
the plant is on site and being stored
and it's finally time to plant
you're going to want to be there for
that to achieve the layout that you
specified
uh the correct spacing again but also
now's the final opportunity to do one
last look at the plant after that
storage period
and at this time the plants are all
going to be unpotted and you're going to
get to see
the root system this uh hydrangea here
actually has a really lovely nice
fibrous root network
not too dense lots of clean white growth
you can actually nice fresh soil smell
to it
no dead material but also it's not
overly rooted it's not what we call pot
bound
there can be a condition where if the
plant has been in the pot too long
actually the roots will start to grow
and encircle around the perimeter of the
pot which forms a barrier
so actually this is a really nice
looking root system
if it were pot bound or if there weren't
circling roots
this would be another opportunity for
you to reject the plant
but no this is a good plant and it's
time for it to go in the ground
at that point once it's in the ground
you own it
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu